[Musique]
bonne année à tous et à toutes bienvenue
dans cette toute première vidéo de
l'année années 2000 21 qui commence
j'espère bien pour vous j'espère que les
fêtes se sont bien passées j'espère que
vous avez pris de bonnes résolutions
surtout vous allez entamer cette année
2021 bien par rapport à cette année 2020
était un peu chaotique dont je vous
souhaite le meilleur
tout se passe bien pour vous votre
famille l'amour la santé toussa toussa
toussa et que vous ayez plein de beau
gadget texte si c'est ce que vous aimez
si c'est ce que fait plaisir et ça c'est
cool on va commencer aujourd'hui par
près d'un objet qui se plie un objectif
qui est flexible plus tôt c'est cette
montre là c'est la nubie watch du bien
est une marque qui fabrique notamment
des smartphones je vous en ai déjà parlé
par le passé et là ils sont sont leur
deuxième monde connecté mais première
virée est vraiment grand public est
intéressante et la grande particularité
qu'elle l'a celle là c'est qu'elle a un
écran flexible alors la question qu'on
va se pose aujourd'hui c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va venir faire avec une montre
avec un écran flexible quel est
l'intérêt pour quoi faire qu'est-ce que
je vais faire d'un écran flexible sur
une jonque sur un smartphone on comprend
l'usaf qu'est-ce qu'on peut soit
l'agrandir soit le rétrécir on l'a vu
notamment du côté de chez samsung avec
le z folle de 2 on l'a vu avec le z flip
sur une mode c'est un peu différente
quand on regarde comme ça effectivement
il ya un côté un peu what the fuck c'est
rigolo
maintenant est ce qu un réal usage est
ce que c'est vraiment confort à utiliser
regardait ce que c'est de cette manière
là qu'il faut l'intégrer comme le fait
du bien avec sa lubie ahwach est-ce que
ce modèle est réussi et avant toute
chose pour moi il ya vraiment deux
choses à mieux distinguer ici
la première c'est l'écran qui va être
flexible est-ce que cet écran flexible
est intéressant qu'elle qu'elle est la
deuxième chose c'est l'intégration sur
cette montre l'intégration qu'on a fait
nubia avec le choix notamment
l'adaptation au niveau de l'eau est ce
la partie logicielle on va donc faire le
tour complet en commençant par
l'intégration du point de vue matériel
avant de commencer par l'intégration
d'un point de vue logiciel ici du bien
nous a sorti une montre avec un écran
flexible de 4,01 pouces
on est sur des solutions 2900 pas 192
pixels c'est un format qui est assez
particulier qu'on ne connaît pas ce que
je vais trouver intéressant sur ce
format c'est effectivement quand vous le
regardez que vous débutez comme ça que
vous prenez sous vos yeux
il ya un côté vraiment ont un peu au
fait moi ou on a l'impression d'avoir
une montre qui vient du futur un peu il
suit d'un james bond
après l'alsace c'est un peu moins saïdi
écran qui se plaît on est sur une
technopole aide ici c'est de l'amoled ce
que vous allez pouvoir modifier quand
vous allez porter votre monde savait
juste être les petites extrémités qui
vont venir se plier pour s'ajuster à la
taille de votre poignet je vous cache
pas que c'est une honte qui est assez
gros ce qui ne va pas aller à tous les
poignets si vous avez des tout petits
pois nitoo fin je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit faite pour vous après le
côté qui est plutôt sympa si vous pouvez
venir changer les bracelets pour
l'adapter à la taille de votre poignet
personnellement j'ai mis un tout petit
bracelet parce que les bracelets un peu
gros ne conviendrait pas à la taille de
mon panier j'ai des petits poneys donc
c'est forcément vous vous en douterez ça
fera pas de job c'est une montée quand
même assez imposante elle fait 98 g
une fois au poignet on ne la sent pas on
oublie très rapidement dans le meilleur
des cas et bien ça ne servira pas à
venir vous muscler l'avant bras je puis
vous assurer que vraiment on sent
globalement pas grand chose le design
est fait à base de céramique et
d'aluminium
elle transpire la solidité les finitions
pour moi sont vraiment bien maîtrisée de
la part de nubie à que ce soit aussi
bien au niveau de l'intégration de
l'écran que du contour que de votre
boîtier personnellement ça fonctionne
bien là on a un gros bouton il ya un
seul bouton peut venir actionner ici et
qu'il attire vraiment comme une honte
très masculine au niveau des clichés des
standards elle est quand même d'une très
massif ça vous vous en douterez
l'épaisseur est là et puis ce gros
boutons vient renforcer en plus cette
idée là votre bouton vous servira de
zone of voulait s'est appuyé 10 secondes
vous l'éteignez peut être un appui long
vouloir démarrer et lorsque vous êtes
puis quand elle est en usage
eh bien vous arrivez au menu dans lequel
pouvait venir naviguer très facilement
c'est une honte qui est certifié ip 54
résistante à l'eau et à la poussière
alors évitez d'aller faire les grandes
baignade avec mais par contre pour vous
laver les mains voudra absolument aucun
problème et si vous êtes dans la rue et
qui se met à pleuvoir s'affale tard côté
performances on trouve ici un processeur
de qualcomm c'est un snapdragon were
2100 on a un giga de ram et 8 gigas de
stockage pour venir toquer de la musique
et des photos vous allez voir que
réalité c'est pas si évident que ça on
va retrouver batterie de 425 millions
terreur à l'intérieur
nubien nous annonce trente six heures
d'autonomie en usage normal et jusqu'à 7
jours en mode serving conseiller en
économie d'énergie
trente six heures à quelque chose près
on a 24 heures voire un peu plus on a
une journée une journée et demi donc là
dessus le challenge est remplie au
développement vous avez un capteur par
le train de mesurer votre fréquence
cardiaque grands standards également la
partie matérielle moi je trouve plutôt
intéressante maintenant ce qui est
bizarre et je vous le cache pas c'est
vraiment le fait d'avoir cet écran
flexible
j'aime beaucoup les écrans flexibles je
trouve extrêmement pertinent comme je
vous le dis quand il ya des usages
derrière si l'idée c'est d'avoir un
effet waouh
on l'a maintenant le dresse derrière je
suis clairement pas convaincu puisque
lorsque vous l'avez face à vous ça veut
donc dire que vous ne voyez pas ce qu'il
va y avoir sur la partie pliée sur le
haut mais également sur le bas donc
lorsque vous naviguez ça vient rajouter
en immersion voit on a plus d'immersion
mais les autres parties de l'écran on ne
les voit pas très peu et ils servent à
pas grand chose
est ce qu'il aurait fallu emmené l'écran
un peu moins loin sur l'eau et sur le
bas pour garder cet effet profondeur
lorsque vous allez lire naviguer
peut-être je sais pas pour moi j'arrive
pas à trancher ce qui est sûr c'est que
la partie du haut vous ne la verrez pas
voudraient venir tourner votre poignet
on se fait mal ça ne sert strictement
rien donc la partie du hockey qui se
passe vous n'utiliserez pas la partie du
bape pourrait potentiellement la
regarder si vous êtes faits niant que
vous ne voulez pas mettre votre poignet
face à vous on voit bon voilà il ya un
côté très immersif il ya un côté un peu
sympa il ya toujours cet effet whaou
mais dans l'absolu je vous assure comme
ça j'ai pas réellement d'usagé le
bénéfice est pour moi tout de suite ça
ne sert strictement à rien si ce n'est
d'avoir un cadran qui est très sympa
lorsque vous regardez leur et pour venir
vous la péter devant vos amis mais s'ils
n'ont globalement pas grand intérêt
maintenant la question c'est toute la
partie software puisqu'ici au tourne sur
nubia were os 1.0 j'ai la dernière
version
à l'heure actuelle à cacher cette vidéo
comme tout le monde connecté vous pouvez
passer un coup de fil avec recevoir des
messages de notification consulter votre
agenda
voir votre rythme cardiaque
potentiellement vous pouvez apporter de
la musique sauf que au final c'est pas
extrêmement simple moi j'ai utilisé avec
un iphone il ya une application qui est
disponible sur ios mais également sur
android l'application c'est nubia ware
est en réalité vous pouvez pas aller
très très loin vous n'avez pas beaucoup
de possibilités
la première chose à faire c'est à venir
connecter votre montre en wifi pour
venir chercher la dernière mise à jour
je me dis ok je suis connecté ma montre
je dois pouvoir venir me connecter à mon
compte spotify pour récupérer la musique
eh bien non parce que si je
quatorze d'applications je ne peux donc
pas téléchargé spotify et donc je ne
peux pas écouter toute la musique que je
veux lire mon abonnement
il faudrait que j'aie de la musique
directement dans mon smartphone et que
je puisse ensuite la connecter à ma
montre
sauf qu'ici moi je suis sur ios il
demande de mettre mon smartphone par
passe de connexion et que je connecte ma
montre en wifi sur les hotspots créée
par mon smartphone pour envoyer la
musique depuis un moment on est quoi on
est en 2013 2010 où on est en 2021 pour
moi il ya un problème là dessus ça
fonctionne pas l'usagé n'est pas bon on
se rajoutent des barrières donc on va
pas les faire autre problème pour les
non anglophones et bien c'est votre
montre aller uniquement en anglais il ya
absolument pas de version en français ça
ça peut être un petit peu embêtant autre
point qui me fait râler c'est que vous
donnez de santé données de sport
resteront dans votre montre et vous ne
pourrez pas les partager avec un apple
santé oms avec d'autres applications de
santé que vous utiliser au quotidien
donc on reste enfermé chez nubia et
celle du bien il n'y a pas beaucoup de
possibilités c'est extrêmement frustrant
le truc que je trouve par contre
vraiment sympa d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est l'affichage de l'heure
vous avez des écrans qui sont super beau
pour lire naviguer entre quelques autres
sens vraiment bien fait c'est super
intéressant et autres points que je
trouve aussi super cool
et bien c'est que vous avez à
fonctionner qui s'appelle barrage alors
comme ça on n'y serait plus bel âge vous
allez dans marquis switch et là vous
avez différents écrans qui sont super
sympas et qui vont venir s'animer sans
votre montre alors une fois de plus on
rit d'un côté un petit peu what the fuck
pour ça fasse beau devant les copains
mais sur l'usagé au quotidien pour moi
il ya normalement pas vraiment d'intérêt
ou mal on sait également que je peux
venir uploadé mes photos tournemire
customiser mon écran personnellement
j'ai pas trouvé comment le faire une
fois de plus c'est frustrant je peux
venir synchroniser mes contacts et mon
calendrier donc je peux consulter mes
rendez vous à venir
ok pourquoi pas mais ça j'ai envie de
dire que c'est quand même une des
fonctions de base de n'importe quel
monde connecté aujourd'hui donc là ça va
pas casser trois pattes à un canard
réalité mise à part quelques usages un
peu standard répondre à un appel voire
des messages qui me sens voyait cette
montre qu'il n'est pas en faire grand
chose effectivement je peux aller faire
du sport j'ai choix entre quatre modes
de sport 4 modes de sport pour une monde
connecté en 2021
pour moi c'est pas satisfaisant
certainement pas bon du tout pour je
puisse venir acheter cette montre
d'autant plus comme je le disais il
n'est pas question d'application je ne
peux donc pas venir télécharger
d'applications tierces 5 sert
strictement à rien donc si vous êtes
sportif et que vous voulez le mans
connectés clairement c'est pas la nuit
bien voir ce qu'il vous faut
la nouvelle vague elle est belle elle
est chouette elle a un effet whaou
elle vous permettra de venir vous
pété devant vos amis pour 219 euros mais
au-delà de ça elle sert à rien j'aime
bien l'objet je trouve beau je trouve
séduisant j'aime bien nourrir la
réflexion mettre un écran flexible sur
une montre pourquoi pas mais pas intégré
cette manière là ça demanderait à venir
complètement repensé lusage et la
manière dont on va venir à interagir
avec notre écran ici globalement c'est
pas réussi le produit est bon et de beau
pour moi du ghana pas réussi sa copie a
vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas aux commentaires qu est ce
que vous pensez de cette news via watch
est ce que vous trouvez qu'un effet web
ou est ce qu'elle vous plaît est ce que
vous pourriez beaux essais santé et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout
l'intégration logicielle et surtout
selon vous si on vient à intégrer un
écran flexible sur une montre de quelle
manière un constructeur devrait s'y
prendre pour qu'il réalise âge et que ce
soit intéressant
mark et moi ça en bas aux commentaires
et cantal on se retrouve très vite parce
que très vite la voie qui part où on se
retrouve très vite parce qu'il ya plein
de choses qui arrivent
il ya plein plein de belles nouveautés
il y aura plein de nouveautés tout au
long de l'année vous en parlerai au fur
et à mesure vous invite donc à venir me
rejoindre hier vous abonner s'est pas
mis le cap sur son banc beaucoup d'amour
très gros bisous et à très vite tout est
encore bonne année thème du maintien
[Musique]
m
et yann